hi I'm Emily Ekins and I'm the polling
director at Reason Foundation we
recently conducted a poll of Americans
on landlines and cellphones asking them
questions about government spending the
debt ceiling gun control and drug reform
I'd like to tell you about some of the
results we have several questions about
government spending the federal budget
deficit and the debt ceiling we found
sixty-four percent of americans oppose
raising the debt ceiling one of the
reasons is that only a quarter think
that failing to raise the debt ceiling
would actually result in an economic
crisis since 1990 federal government
spending per person has increased
thirty-nine percent adjusted for
inflation we found that only seventeen
percent of Americans felt that this
increased spending had improved their
quality of life this helps explain why
only twelve percent of americans think
that rolling spending levels back to the
1990s levels would hurt the economy we
asked a number of questions about drug
policy we found that republicans
democrats and independents all agree
that the federal government should not
get involved in states that have
legalized the recreational use of
marijuana for instance republicans
democrats and independents all agree
that the federal government should not
arrest individuals who use grow or sell
marijuana in the states that have
legalized it in light of new proposals
for gun legislation we asked a number of
questions about gun control first we
found that 51 percent of americans
believe that individuals should be
allowed to own assault weapons
forty-four percent disagree and believe
they should be prohibited we asked
Americans if they thought the assault
weapons ban would have prevented the
shooter in Newtown Connecticut had the
law still been in effect we found that
only twenty-seven percent of Americans
felt like it would we asked them why and
of these Americans they felt it would
have prevented the shooter from
obtaining the weapons that he used this
is particularly interesting given that
Connecticut already has an assault
weapons ban on the books and the weapons
that lambs are used were legal under
state law to learn more about what
Americans think about entitlement reform
cutting defense spending taxes and more
please visit reason.com forward slash
poll
you